[Applause]
[Music]
if I mentioned Switzerland I'm sure many
of you automatically think of things
like banking fine jewelry and safes the
mother of all tax Havens the country
where money never sleeps the place where
bank accounts are so much more important
than food itself am I wrong I'm sure I'm
not and things have changed a lot lately
yes it's true Switzerland is not what it
used to be in order to gain access to
the European common market the Swiss
Confederation has had to make a lot of
concessions for example the legislation
on banking secrecy had to be completely
changed reforms that naturally have had
consequences
[Music]
Switzerland has been progressively
losing positions in some of the rankings
that serve to determine the degree of
economic freedom of a country yes
Switzerland still has very low taxes and
it is still the second country in the
world in terms of economic freedom
according to the Heritage Foundation
ranking but if we look at the
regulations it is no longer such a
paradise destination in fact the country
has been falling progressively in the
world bank's doing Business ranking to
reach the 36th place it currently
occupies to put this in context it was
ranked 19th in 2008.
but let's make no mistake the Swiss
continue to have and to offer to the
rest of the world one of the best legal
safety nets in the world for Investments
savings or simply for depositing wealth
and I'm not just talking about money
that is to say Switzerland is a skiing
Paradise an industrial power and an
important technological Center but above
all it is a gigantic Safe Money works of
art Jewels practically everything
without going any further here on
visualpolitik we made a video about
Switzerland and the art industry and
what can I say everyone trusts the Swiss
franc and we've already explained why on
our sister Channel visual economic
however as I already said a lot has
changed in recent years not only because
Switzerland is no longer exactly the
country we all imagine it to be but also
because competition has emerged today
there are other countries in the world
that can even boast that they are
gaining ground in the favorite activity
of the Swiss being the meeting place for
Millionaires and billionaires from all
over the world in fact we can find one
country that not only surpasses
Switzerland in many Financial Fields but
also thanks to its geographical location
could become the new Refuge of the
world's largest fortunes any idea what
country we're talking about three two
one exactly Singapore
foreign
[Music]
that many of you would have guessed it
well take a look Swiss Financial Center
faces growing Global pressure Hong Kong
will probably overtake Switzerland
ending a run of more than 200 years of
Swiss dominance in the private
cross-border wealth management sector
BCG wrote Singapore will even come close
to ousting Switzerland from second place
in the coming years yes I know the news
highlights Hong Kong but there is a bit
of a catch Hong Kong is a very
significant financial center
specializing mainly in China that is to
say its position has a lot to do with
being the financial gateway to and from
the Asian giant so it has an advantage
but let's not get sidetracked the fact
is that Switzerland has been a Haven for
the wealth of the great fortunes for the
last two centuries or so coinciding with
the time when the West was the only
really rich thriving and prosperous area
on the entire planet well for some time
now Singapore has been developing into
something very very similar in Asia and
open Safe and Sound business savings and
investment environment
[Music]
[Applause]
and don't forget we are not only talking
about China and the great fortunes of
this country but also about economies
with amazing projections for the coming
decades such as Indonesia Malaysia and
Vietnam all of them are just a stone's
throw away from this city-state and if
that were not enough established
heavyweights such as Japan and South
Korea as well as China are also
relatively close so the question is
could we say that this unusual Southeast
Asian city-state is set to become the
next Switzerland where does all the
wealth coming into Singapore come from
and what exactly are the reasons why
people choose this place to park their
cash well we're going to answer these
and other questions in this video but
hold up before we get ahead of ourselves
let's talk about a serious matter are
you doing anything to stop your personal
information from being sold on the
internet without your knowledge
according to the identity theft resource
Center's annual report on data breaches
there were 68 more breaches in 2021 than
the previous year yikes but don't throw
in the towel just yet you have the right
to protect your privacy by asking data
Brokers to remove your more information
the only downside is that doing it
manually would take longer than a
political debate thankfully our sponsor
incogney is here to help their
three-step solution will have you
covered first create an account and
enter your details second grant them the
right to go to work for you they will
contact the data Brokers on your behalf
to request the removal of your personal
data and third relax and watch them work
they will handle any objections from the
data Brokers and keep you informed of
their progress every step of the way and
the best part of all the first 100 of
you who use the code politic en via the
link below will get 20 off at Incognito
so don't let this opportunity pass you
by
[Music]
The Keeper of the money
[Applause]
Switzerland remains a major Haven for
Global wealth according to Deloitte in
2020 the country's financial industry
managed 2.6 trillion with a capital T in
international Assets in total their
financial assets exceeded 4.1 trillion
in 2021 to give you an idea this is more
than 40 more than the entire size of the
financial system of a country like Spain
a country whose population is 5.5 times
larger than that of Switzerland well
Singapore is still a long way behind in
total according to the Basel
International Bank for settlements its
Financial system manages just over 2
trillion in assets about half of that of
the Swiss system but it is growing much
more rapidly Singapore is fast becoming
a major Wealth Management Center in Asia
and threatens to overtake Hong Kong
itself this is something that we've
talked about on several occasions here
on visualpolitik XI jinping's assault on
Hong Kong traditionally the Center the
financial heart of Asia has left the
former British colony with a very
unflattering reputation
[Music]
you know the story basically the legal
certainty that existed before the
Chinese authorities came to the table
bypassed International agreements and
took over the city no longer exists or
at least it is fast disappearing not
surprisingly this is something that
scares away International capital and
investors having your money under the
control of XI jinping's People's
Republic of China would you trust them
to never get their hands on it exactly
no thanks logically this is something
that affects International investors but
also the large Chinese portfolios that
until now have used Hong Kong as an
escape route as a safe deposit box out
of the reach of the Chinese Communist
party because what could happen but
since that is no longer a solution or at
best it is no longer completely
guaranteed it is time to seek Refuge
elsewhere and guess what this is exactly
why the financial industry in Singapore
is having a rebirth everything indicates
that in a few years Singapore will not
only surpass Hong Kong as the Main
Financial Center but it will be to the
Asian continent what Switzerland is to
the rest of the world take a look
[Music]
according to Deloitte Hong Kong's
International Market volume that is the
number of transactions in equities
deposits indices or other Investments
grew faster than Singapore's between
2010 and 2016. however from then on
things started to change and from 2016
onwards it fell below Singapore's growth
between 2017 and 2020 and the forecast
is that things will only get worse yes
Hong Kong's financial sector is still
growing but its dynamism is no longer
the same meanwhile Singapore is growing
steadily
[Music]
now financial investments are not the
only thing Singapore is taking off in
not at all huge amounts of foreign money
are also coming in in the form of direct
Investments such as setting up companies
or buying real estate and naturally as
you can imagine one of the biggest
players in this whole process is Chinese
Capital the pandemic accelerated this
process but we're talking about an
underlying trend
foreign
according to the financial times the
number of family offices that is funds
or investment platforms dedicated to
managing the large Estates of individual
families grew by fourteen hundred
percent in Singapore between 2018 and
the end of 2021. the number of funds has
grown from about 50 to more than 700 and
it is estimated by the end of 2022 that
figure could be around 1500 of these 40
would be in capital originating from
mainland China likewise as many as 500
Chinese companies were registered in
Singapore in 2022 alone from there they
will direct investments into countries
such as India and many other booming
places in the region
and if anyone thought that with the end
of the covered zero policy in China
things were going to calm down well
everything indicates that exactly the
opposite is happening as China reopens
flight of wealthy Chinese to Singapore
set to accelerate and look according to
the consulting firm Henley and partners
which advises High net worth individuals
on obtaining residencies abroad
Singapore received about 2 800 new rich
in 2022. it thus became the third most
popular destination worldwide after the
United Arab Emirates and Australia as a
side note Switzerland ranks fifth in
this ranking with 2 200 arrivals of
wealthy foreigners so although Singapore
does not publish the nationality of the
new residents it is estimated that most
of them are Chinese in other words many
wealthy Chinese saw the writing on the
wall during covid and now that they can
move freely they are betting on fleeing
and yes the danger is Xi Jinping in case
that's what you were wondering
in addition many of these large Chinese
fortunes fear that beijing's tolerance
of letting big money and companies out
of the country country May soon end they
may even begin to restrict such
movements so many believe that if they
don't do so now they may never be able
to put their wealth in safekeeping again
this is representative of the covert
policies and the Chinese Communist
parties regard to limit people's lives
and freedoms so in preparation for the
likely worst they must cast their safety
net overseas Joseph fan Professor
specializing in finance and governance
at University of Queensland in addition
another major reason why the choice of
many large Chinese fortunes has been
Singapore has to do with the Russian
invasion of Ukraine yeah that's what I
said with Ukraine but what on Earth does
Ukraine have to do with Singapore well
you see let me explain the distrust
towards XI jinping's increasingly
nationalistic Vision generates fear and
doubts that he may ultimately end up
taking some serious action in Taiwan
which could push the West to impose
sanctions against China that is why many
Chinese are opting for places that could
be more neutral rather than taking their
wealth only to Europe or the United
States and Singapore well it meets all
those requirements obviously all this
also has consequence is at the local
level
[Music]
for example housing prices in Singapore
grew by 8.6 in 2022 alone and according
to Market analysts Chinese buyers bought
the most Condominiums out of all foreign
buyers and keep in mind that we are
talking about a microstate of only 5.6
million inhabitants in an area barely
larger than the city of Madrid almost
half of which is mountains or protected
areas so as you can imagine it's not as
easy as simply building more and more
housing to accommodate this huge demand
this is in fact one of the major
problems of the city but we are not
going to go into more details about this
issue because we already talked about
the housing problem in Singapore in a
past video that will link for you in the
description now aside from this matter
what exactly is Singapore offering the
Chinese that so many are suddenly
choosing to seek Refuge there from xi's
growing authoritarianism
you see this city-state is particularly
attractive to the Chinese well it is
close to Hong Kong and Mainland China
and three quarters of the local
population are ethnic Chinese as a
result the Mandarin is widely spoken in
addition to English so The Language and
Cultural barriers are very small
Singapore also has some of the best
schools and universities in the world
this is a factor particularly valued by
Chinese families naturally the city also
has a well-developed wealth management
industry and to top it off the large
presence of Chinese companies in the
country is making it possible to weave a
whole Chinese business cluster
for example bite dance the Chinese
company that owns the popular Tick Tock
app has a major office in Singapore and
in fact it is betting on increasing its
presence until it becomes practically a
sort of second headquarters Tick Tock
owner bike dance to invest billions in
Singapore over three years it plans to
invest billions of dollars and recruit
hundreds of employees in Singapore after
opting to base its southeast Asia
Regional headquarters there this is just
one example among dozens and dozens that
we could list
because the truth is that Singapore is
also becoming a major hub for technology
companies especially for those oriented
towards finance and of course let's see
the city has first-class technological
infrastructure a top-rate educational
system that is very oriented to
information Technologies regulations
that are not too dense and a lot of
financial companies in other words
fintechs are in their element here in
fact this is perhaps one of the most
thriving sectors in Singapore but is not
the only one do you want to know how the
future of the Singaporean economy is
shaping up for this kind of rebirth do
you want to know how Singapore aspires
to become nothing less than the richest
country in the world well let's take a
look
[Music]
Singapore of the future
Singapore has been on a roll of late and
its strong growth as a financial center
and a Haven for high net worth
individuals is making it possible for
the government to set new economic goals
for example at the end of 2022 the
strategy up until 2030 was established
and the question is what exactly does
Singapore hope to become well you see we
must start from the assumption that some
of the most developed sectors in the
country are currently fintechs
biotechnology and medical tourism
to give you an idea of the 100 local
companies with the fastest growth
between 2018 and 2021 10. are fintech
eight are in logistics and
transportation and seven are in energy
and Utilities in fact there were one
thousand and two fintechs registered in
Singapore alone as of June 2022
although naturally you may not know
offhand whether this is a lot or a
little
[Music]
well if you compare it with the just
under 10 000 that exist in the United
States and keep in mind it is the world
leader we quickly realize that there are
a lot of them in Singapore the United
States the world leader in this field
has only 10 times more fintech companies
despite having 59 times more inhabitants
but we're not only talking about the
digital world what if I also told you
that one of the sectors that has been
growing the most likely in this micro
country is precisely manufacturing what
if I told you that this sector is the
top priority of the 2030 plan yes
despite the fact Singapore is a very
small place the manufacturing sector
accounts for 22 of its GDP and to give
you an idea in Spain France and the
United Kingdom this sector accounts for
13 10 and 9 respectively in fact one out
of every eight jobs in Singapore is in
manufacturing as you can see it's not
all big skyscrapers of Banks and
insurance companies there is a lot more
to Singapore however if you're thinking
of shoe or toy factories you can put
that out of your mind
foreign
specializes in highly Advanced High
value-adding manufacturing such as
Electronics this includes semiconductors
Precision Engineering chemicals and also
the production of components for the
Aerospace industry in Total Advanced
Industries account for Just Around 80
percent of all production
[Music]
just as Switzerland has succeeded in
creating highly specialized and
sophisticated Industries such as the
biomedical industry Singapore is doing
exactly the same but now the government
intends to go much further and has
created a plan in which Robotics and
artificial intelligence play a key role
the goal is to eventually reduce local
low value added jobs to an absolute
minimum
the idea is not only that low value
added jobs will be reduced in number but
that those who work them will commute
daily from the border Malaysian state of
Johor and the truth is that they are on
the right track to give you an idea in
the five-year period
2017-2021 manufacturing labor
productivity grew by an average of 11.9
percent per year
now why do singaporeans believe that
they have to strengthen manufacturing
instead of for example specializing
completely in the service sector at Full
Throttle well you see just like the
Swiss did instead of discarding any kind
of gamble on anything beyond Banks
insurance companies or I don't know the
investment industry the government wants
to promote a strong local industry that
is not so exposed to Global economics
ups and downs in other words
diversification with a capital D but in
fields are very high added value
uh
we also told you here on visualpolitik
how Singapore is doing something similar
with the primary sector the government
is promoting the creation of high-tech
Farms all over the country and we'll
also link that video in the description
all things considered the fact is that
to achieve all these objectives
Singapore apparently has all the
necessary ingredients a huge number of
Highly qualified professionals a huge
amount of capital ready to invest in all
kinds of projects a lot of legal
security low taxes top infrastructure
and Communications and a long list of
professionals and investors willing to
move there so you see Singapore really
does seem to be on the verge of becoming
the new Switzerland with a very similar
formula for Success albeit updated to
the current ERA and its Regional context
as you can see the Swiss are still
richer but that may change very soon but
now it's your turn do you think that
Singapore's model for attracting High
net worth individuals is replicable in
other countries leave us your opinion
Below in the comments and if you like
the video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to our channel so you don't
miss any news and remember if you do
like what we do you can support us to
keep creating more and better content by
joining our community on patreon in
return you will receive a lot of extra
content we'll leave you the link below
in the description once again thank you
so much for watching all the best I'll
see you next time
[Music]